les gens commencent à avoir peur parce
que ils se disent il y a un tueur en
liberté peut-être un roodur il s'est
attaqué à notre voisine à notre ami à
notre sœur et pourquoi il s'attaquera
pas à nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aussi 18 mars 2013 une cinquantaine
d'anonymes sont rassemblés dans les rue
de Saint-Mars la Jaille un petit village
en Loire
Atlantique tous sont des proches dan
Barbeau 38 ans portéit disparu depuis
maintenant 2 jours mais s'ils sont là
c'est aussi pour soutenir Didier barbau
le mari fou d'inquiétude ça fait déjà 48
he plus de 48 heur qu'elle a disparu
avec tous les amis on a parcouru 25 km à
la rond chemin et forêt étend tout et on
a rien on a pas de nouvelles on a pas de
voiture on a aucune aucune
piste c'est l'histoire d'un mari que
rien n'arrête pour tenter de retrouver
sa femme
[Musique]
l'histoire d'un couple fusionnel mais
qui cache une terrible
blessure mais aussi celle d'un homme qui
va trahir tous ceux qui croient en
[Musique]
Lui là ça fait froid dans le dos quand
on apprend qu'il y a un cadavre dans la
[Musique]
voiture les gens commencent à avoir peur
parce qu'ils se disent il y a un tueur
en
liberté au funéraille Didier va prendre
la parole il nous dit faut le retrouver
faut le retrouver parce que je le tuerai
moi-même c'est un drame terrible pour ce
couple qui avait tout misé sur l'arrivée
de cet
[Musique]
enfant il se comportait comme quelqu'un
qui avait vraiment perdu tout sens à sa
vie samedi 16 mars 2013
avri dans le département de la Loire
Atlantique la matinée s'achève
paisiblement en ce samedi matin Didier
Barbeau 40 ans agriculteur est à pied
d'œuvre depuis
6H30 alors qu'il s'apprête à rentrer
chez lui pour déjeuner il reçoit un
appel qui va bouleverser sa vie il a
reçu un coup de fil des collègues de
travail de sa femme Anne marbaau lui
disant que ce samedi matinlà elle a pas
pris son poste comme
d'habitude Anne Barbeau 38 ans est
caissière dans un supermarché situé à 6
km de la ferme
familiale et cela n'est pas dans ses
habitudes de ne pas se présenter à son
travailétait jamais en retard à son
travail ses collègues c'est ce qui les a
inquiété quelque part parce qu'ells ont
dit depuis le temps qu'elle travaille
avec nous jamais elle n'a été en retard
donc là il y avait quelque chose elle a
des responsabilités au sein de
l'entreprise dans laquelle elle
travaille et elle ne serait jamais est
parti sans
avoir signalé son absence il lui est
forcément arrivé malheure on pense pas
au au pire mais Anne est est en danger
Anne est en difficulté chose
inquiétantes le téléphone portable
d'Anne est sur
messagerie très inquiet son mari Didier
Barbeau appelle immédiatement les
gendarme il s'est forcément passé
quelque
chose il explique aux gendarmes que son
épouse a quitté le matin la le domicile
du couple et qu'il n'a aucune
explication à cela et qu'en conséquence
il s'en inquiète et leur demande de
d'engager des recherches seulement anné
majeur pour les gendarmes sa disparition
qui date seulement de quelques heures
n'est pour l'instant pas inquiétante ils
se veulent même rassurant la disparition
est très récente les gendarmes ne
s'inquiète pas ne s'affole pas peut-être
a-t-elle un amant peut-être s'est-elle
fâchée avec son Marie et elle a décidé
d'aller faire un petit tour Didier lui
n'est pas du même avis il sent que
quelque chose de grave est arrivé à son
épouse alors il va prendre les choses en
main et tout faire pour retrouver
Anne l'idée c'est de retrouver la
voiture d'Anne Barbeau on sait que c'est
une 306 verte pour ne rien laisser au
hasard Didier a besoin de renfort alors
il appelle à l'aide ses amis et ses
voisins Patrick gagier un ami proche du
couple se souvient après on a
effectivement fait toute la route
qu'elle prend d'habitude pour aller à
son travail et on a cherché un peu
partout parce que ce qui on voulait
retrouver c'était surtout la voiture
c'était le plus facile pour nous on
était une une vingtaine de personnes
donc on s'est réparti deux à trois par
voiture et puis bah on a commencé à
faire parce qu'il y a beaucoup de forêts
et beaucoup de points d'eau et on a
commencé à à sillonner
nos les endroits où on qu'on connaissait
quoi Didier Barbeau et ses amis
fouillent minutieusement tous les
alentours de la ferme ils refont
plusieurs fois le trajet qu'à emprunté
Anne le matin de sa disparition mais
forcé de constater que ses recherches ne
donnent
rien
Anne est
introuvable plus le temps passait et
plus on s'inquiétait de comment la
retrouver
bah dans quel état est-ce qu'elle était
fatiguée elle aurait été affamée elle
aurait été comment dire en hypothermie
enfin on se demandait comment la
retrouver et puis plus le temps avançait
plus on se disait mais on va la
retrouver ça mal finir quoi les amis
tout de même et la famille évidemment au
fond commence à à voir grandir d'abord
une inquiétude puis une vraie
angoisse la nuit tombe sur V
[Musique]
alors après des heures de recherche
Didier et ses amis résignés décide de
rentrer à la
ferme dès le lendemain le domicile de
Didier barbau devient une espèce de
quartier général où s'organise les
recherches et pour mettre toutes les
chances de son côté l'agriculteur
sollicite les médias c'est un homme
public qui communique beaucoup mais qui
communique avecob de retrouver sa femme
on voit Didier abattu on le voit soudain
rebondir et et motiver ses amis en
disant on va la trouver on va y arriver
on nabandonnera jamais je la trouverai
j'irai jusqu'au fond de de des puis s'il
le faut au moment où je l'ai rencontré
Didier Barbeau il était chez lui dans sa
ferme sur sa table de salle à manger il
y avait C ou si cartes hgennes les
cartes géographiques sur lesquelles il
traçait des cercles une fois qu'il avait
qu'il avait fait ses recherches sur un
secteur face aux caméras de télévision
Didier Barbeau parcourt sans relâche la
campagne là on a fait d'abord les 15 km
à la ronde et puis aujourd'hui on est
rendu à 25 30 puisquon a aucune piste et
on va agrandir le cercle au fur à mesure
si on a rien voilà il va fouiller dans
les maisons abandonnées dans les coins
les plus retranchés les plus perdus il
semble totalement déterminé à retrouver
ou la voiture ou sa fin tout ce qui peut
être exploré la il y a de la part de cet
homme une
oui une frénésie une une une volonté une
ténacité infatigable infatigable
d'explorer chaque centimètre carré de de
terrain de bâtiment pour retrouver
didier barbau est
infatigable sa détermination à retrouver
sa femme lui attire la sympathie de tous
les habitants de la région on a pas le
choix on va pas rester lesains les bras
croiser quoi donc faut être sur le
terrain et chercher quoi pour absolument
faire avancer l'enquête l'attente est
est insupportable aussi
[Musique]
quoi on a fait du chemin on avait
largement écarté on est parti plus de 60
km donc ça faisait quand même loin les
chemins les bois les les bâtiments
abandonnés il y a plus rien qui de
hasard on se dit maintenant si on est
passé sur ce secteur on a on a quadrillé
le secteur elle peut pas être là chaque
secteur chaque je va dire pousce de
carré de terrain chaque centimètre de
carré de terrain mais on va le
l'examiner le lendemain matin amis et
voisins reprennent les recherches et
tout le monde s'inquiète de peur que la
jeune femme et fait une fugue pire
qu'elle a mis fin à ses jours car Anne
Barbeau cach en
réalité uneès grande
[Musique]
blessure en effet le couple a vécu un
terrible drame 7 ans plus tôt ils ont
perdu leur unique enfant à la naissance
une petite fille c'est un drame terrible
pour ce couple
qui avait tout misé sur l'arrivée de cet
enfant on s'est dit peut-être que Anne
elle a eu un petit un petit coup de
cafard et puis qu'elle est dans un petit
coin en train de se reposer réfléchir et
puis qu'elle va revenir plus tard quoi
suite au décès de cet enfant Anne
Barbeau a appris qu'elle ne pourrait
plus jamais être
enceinte dès lors la vie du couple s'en
ressent Anne Didier s'isole soudé dans
l'adversité c'est un choc c'est un
bouleversement que tous les proches
ressentent ils se referme sur eux-même
mais plutôt que de se détruire plutôt
que de se déchirer ils se referment sur
eux-même pour c'est l'impression que
tous en non se retrouver mieux former un
couple être ensemble ils se soutiennent
l'un et l'autre dans cette épreuve
terrible terrible terrible ah oui pour
moi annéidier c'était c'était un couple
que rien ne pouvait déstabilisé après
tout ce qu' avaient passé les épreuves
étant que normalement ça soude cette
épreuve semble avoir simentter la
relation entre Didier et sa femme aux
yeux de tous ils incarnent le couple
idéal tous ceux qui connaissent le
couple tous ceux qui ont pu les voir
vivre ensemble les décrivaient comme
extrêmement Unis Anne et Didier
représente un couple le fusionnel ils
sentendent merveilleusement bien ça fait
15 ans qu'ils sont mariés qu'ils ne se
quittent pour ainsi dire
jamais cependant ces derniers temps Anne
barbau allait mieux preuve en est cette
vidéo amateur tourn seulement 3 jours
avant sa
disparition ce soirl lors d'une fête
pour l'anniversaire d'un ami Anne paraît
heureuse et
insouciante il faut dire que le couple a
appris une bonne nouvelle leur demande
d'adoption a été acceptée et un petit
garçon d'origine africaine doit bientôt
rejoindre leur
foyer ils sont déjà en train de préparer
la chambre de l'enfant ils ont eu tous
les accords et ils attendent à présent
de recevoir l'enfant qui pourrait être
le leur dans le cadre de cette adoption
à 38 ans Anne barbau avait donc tout
pour être heureuse alors pourquoi
aurait-elle décidé de
disparaître l'hypothèse d'une fugue fait
long feu la piste est
abandonnée lundi 18 mars le mari d'Anne
fou d'inquiétude décide de mettre la
pression aux gendarmes auquel il
reproche de ne pas l'avoir pris au
sérieux chose rarissime Didier organise
une manifestation il y a une centaine de
personnes qui sont allées devant la
gendarmerie pour inciter la gendarmerie
à à faire quelque chose parce que
c'était pas possible que ça continue
comme ça ça fait déjà 48 he plus de 48
he qu'elle a disparu avec tous les amis
on a parcouru 25 km à la rond chemin
forêt étend tout et on a rien on a pas
de nouvell on a pas de voiture on a
aucune aucune piste et la détermination
de Didier Barbeau va porter ses
fruits 48 he après la disparition d'ne
les gendarmes lanc alors les recherche
et commence par reconstituer son emploi
du temps dans les heures qui ont précédé
sa
disparition la veille au soir le couple
dîne dans la cuisine de la ferme
[Musique]
familiale vers 22h ils partent se
coucher il est 6h le lendemain matin
lorsque comme à son habitude Didier
Barbeau se lève Anne reste au
lit à
7h45 l'épouse part au volant de sa 306
verte pour rejoindre le supermarché de
Candé là où elle
travaille puis plus rien à partir de cet
instantl
Anne ne répond plus au
[Musique]
téléphone que s'est-il
passé pour l'instant les gendarmes n'en
ont pas la moindre idée un avis de
recherche est transmis au niveau
national les alentours de V sont passés
au peignef et un hélicoptère survole la
zone à la recherche de la voiture d'an
barbau pendant un jour ou deux
l'hélicoptère survolé la commune et tous
les environs et à ce jour les ét ont été
[Musique]
fouillés et moi les gendarmes me disent
que pour l'instant ils ont aucun indice
force de constater qu'en fin de journée
ni ni l'hélicoptère ni les personnels au
sol n'ont rien
[Musique]
trouvé pendant plusieurs jours les
recherches se
poursuivent lorsqu'enfin la chance
sourit aux
enquêteurs
c'est une guêre une sorte de
surchaussette on la trouve dans un fossé
pas très loin de son domicile une guêre
que portait Anne le jour de sa
disparition il faut mesurer ce que çav
représente à cet instant pour ceux qui
cherchent pour la famille pour les
proches de Didier c'est le premier signe
c'est le premier signe c'est c'est ce
qu'on attendait c'est ce qu'on attendait
voilà qu'on a une trace
Anne n'est pas parti comme cela ne s'est
pas volatilisé il y a une trace une
trace mais une trace
inquiétante Anne Barbeau aurait-elle été
victime d'un crime crapuleux l'hypothèse
est séduisante d'autant que la caissière
avait en sa possession quelque chose qui
aurait pu causer sa perte ce jour-là
Anne barbau détenait la clé caisse du
magasin Super U donc tout de suite les
amis se disent ah elle était responsable
des la caisse peutête qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui a voulu faire un coup pour
voler la recette du supermarché là il y
a quelqu'un qui qui a dû l'arrêter sur
sa route qui l'a fait sortir elle s'est
débatue elle a perdu la guette non pour
nous après c'était là c'était quelqu'un
l'a
enlevé une autre découverte va venir
conforter les gendarmes et les amis d'an
dans cette
hypothèse
le 21 mars 5 jours après la disparition
le jeu de piste macabre se poursuit une
promeneuse découvre le chéquier d'Anne
barbau dans un verger à 15 km de la
ferme familiale et on va découvrir
stupéfaction que dans ce
chéquier C formules de chèque sont
manquantes les C formules de chèque qui
manquent évidemment mil pour un
enlèvement crapuleux milite pour un
enlèvement violent d' barbau on a des
traces d'â
qui augmente l'inquiétude qui augmente
l'angoisse évidemment bien plus qu'elle
ne rassure et qui corrobore l'hypothèse
de l'enlèvement on ne peut plus avec ces
traces croire un seul instant à un
accident qui aurait pu vouloir l'enlever
on pense qu'elle est peut-être retenue
contre son gré quelque part il peut y
avoir une séquestration le mystère
to avri l'enquête piétine les recherches
n'aboutissent pas et chaque jour qui
passe voit les chances de retrouver Anne
barbau vivante
diminuer mais Didier barbau qui
s'accroche à l'espoir de retrouver sa
femme va à nouveau tenter de forcer le
destin Didier barbe va organiser une
marche
blanche le 27 mars pour mobiliser pour
mobiliser autour de la disparition
11 jours après la disparition d'Anne
barbau 600 personnes défilent donc dans
les rues de Candé une marche contre
l'oubli
Didier il était très ému
effectivement abattu de plus en plus
c'est vrai que ça ça commençait à être
plus ça se voyait beaucoup plus sur son
visage et tout ça Didier Barbeau est en
tête au premier rang en tenant l'affiche
sur laquelle se trouve le portrait de
son épouse et la photo de la voiture qui
est recherché avec avec un message très
clair composé le le 17 pour prévenir la
[Musique]
gendarmerie mais même si le visage d'an
barbo s'affiche sur tous les murs et
dans tous les journaux de la région le
mystère de sa disparition reste
entier mais pas pour
longtemps le 28 mars 2013 vers MIDH soit
12 jours après la disparition d'Anne
barbo
un joger va sans le vouloir relancer
l'enquête et immédiatement l'affaire va
prendre une tournure dramatique il est
dans les endroits les plus reculés de la
forêt dans les petits chemins totalement
escarpés et il va tomber tout à fait par
hasard sur un véhicule
calciné de retour chez lui le joger
prévient son oncle Germain
har
les deux hommes retournent sur place et
inspectent minutieusement le
[Musique]
véhicule on a fait un tour de la voiture
on a vu que la voiture était
complètement cramée plus de peneu à
l'intérieur le si éta brûlé entièrement
même même le Chaussis métalique des si
éta
fondu
[Musique]
on a juste jeté un coup d'œil parce que
les vitres étaient cassé par l'explosion
on suppose la voiture donc elle avait
été bien arrosée sans doute on suppose
desessens pour qu'elle broule bien en
inspectant l'épave Germain Amar repère
une plaque minéralogique à côté de la
voiture les plaques étaient même pas
lisies parce que il y avait des feuilles
de collé dessus et descend donc donc a
fallu qu'on frotte les a fallu que je
frotte la plaque pour lire le numéro et
comme j'avais lu l'article dans la
presse par rapport au numéro quand j'ai
commencé à lire ça m'a fait
til la plaque qu'il a retrouvé sur place
correspond à au véhicule d'Anne barbau
et du coup il appelle les gendarmes pour
leur signaler ce qu'ils viennent de
découvrir et ils m'ont dit Monsieur hard
vous bougez pas de place on arrive sur
les lieu immédiatement donc ils sont
arrivés 10 minutes
après la 306 verte d'en barbo vient
enfin d'être retrouvée et même si elle
semble
vide peut-être y a-t-il un indice à
l'intérieur qui va permettre de
retrouver sa
propriétaire les techniciens en
identification criminelle avec leur
combinaison blanche en fil leurs gants
leurs surchaussures il s'agit de ne
surtout pas polluer la scène parce que
ça peut être une scène de crime à
l'intérieur de la voiture pas le moindre
[Applaudissements]
indice le feu est l'ennemi des indices
et le plus le plus grand ennemi des
indices puisqu'il détruit tout et la
voiture ne parle pas ou parle
peu pourant
il y a un détail troublant qu'un
gendarme ne tarde pas à remarquer à
l'arrière du
véhicule en se penchant vers le coffre
arrière là où se trouve le feu les feux
de de signalisation qui ont évidemment
fondu puisque c'est en plastique il y a
donc un trou il y a des gendarmes qui
regardent par le trou et qui voit une
forme un peu ronde qui peut faire penser
à un
crâne c'est qui décide d'ouvrir le
coffre de la voiture et qui tombe sur un
corps entièrement
calciné là ça fait froid dans le dos
quand on apprend qu'il y a un cadavre
dans la voiture des frissons et tout
j'étais loin de penser qu'il y avait un
cadavre dans la voiture
quoi le corps entièrement brûlé
[Musique]
connaissable à cet instantl on ne sait
pas à qui appartient ce corps et on ne
sait pas si ce corps est celui d'un
homme ou d'une femme avec certitude on
ne sait pas non plus bien évidemment de
quoi est mort la personne que l'on
trouve à cet instant-là sur les
lieux et c'est seulement quelques jours
après le 3 avril qu'on apprend
officiellement que l'ADN correspond et
que le corps calciné dans le coffre de
la voiture est bien celui d'
barbau on fait notre une bah sur ce sur
cette révélation et on titre qu'il n'y a
plus aucun espoir pour retrouver Anne
barbau vivante c'est sûr que c'est elle
il y a plus de doute possible et ce
n'est pas tout l'état du corps ne permet
pas de dater la mort d'Anne barbau mais
le rapport d'autopsie va révéler un
détail
[Musique]
essentiel dans le sang de la victime il
n'y a aucune trace de monoxyde de
carbone
cela signifie que la personne qui est
décédée là n'est pas morte par asphixie
et qu'elle n'est pas morte pendant
l'incendie ça veut dire qu'elle a été
tuée avant avant
l'incendie Anne Barb a donc été
assassiné puis son corps a été brûlé
dans sa
[Musique]
voiture avril
2013 formation judiciaire contre X pour
homicide volontaire est
ouverte une cellule d'enquête baptisé
meurtre 49 est mise en place 12
enquêteurs vont travailler en permanence
sur
l'affaire l'annonce de la mort de la
caissière est un choc terrible pour ses
proches on é anéanti complètement on
s'imaginait pas que ça allait finir à ce
pointl aussi catastrophique et aussi que
ça c'était ça qui nous a
complètement ruiné sur le coup quoi
quand on a retrouvé le corps de Anne
dans la voiture on s'est dit ça y est
c'est fini c'est fini an'est plus là
Didier Barbeau quant à lui est effondré
et on voyait que son visage était
décomposé il y avait une douleur il y
avait il se comportait comme quelqu'un
qui avait vraiment perdu tout
sens tout sens à sa vie hein comme toute
personne humaine je dirais il a dit là
il faut m'aider à le retrouver celui qui
a fait
ça AVR où la nouvelle fait l'effet d'une
bombe tout le village
s'interroge un climat de peur de
suspicion et de rumeurs s'installent
rapidement les gens commen à avoir peur
parce que ils se disent il y a un tueur
en liberté peut-être un rodur il s'est
attaqué à notre voisine à notre ami euh
euh à notre sœur et pourquoi il
s'attaquerait pas à nous aussi
connaissant an on comprenait pas
pourquoi on s'était attaqué à elle donc
effectivement pourquoi on n sera pas
attaqué à quelqu'un d'autre
quoi ça ça devenait une psychose dans le
village c'est vrai que de ce côté-là
nous on fermait les portes euh on
fermait les voitures à clé enfin et on a
des amis qui se promenaient avec des
fusils enfin c'était euh
tout le monde avait
peur c'est dans ce climat pesant que les
obsèques d'Anne barbau ont lieu le 19
avril
2013 des centaines de personnes sont
venues de toute la région pour lui
rendre un dernier
hommage l'émotion est à son comble
lorsque l'on apprend que Didier barbau
désormais
veuf
Anne soit enterrée avec sa robe de
marié tout le monde voit dans ce
geste le geste ultime d'un mari adorant
son épouse et qui veut qu'à jamais elle
reste sa femme au funéraille Didier va
prendre la parole et il va remercier
tous ceux qui ont l'ont aidé à chercher
Anne et il va avoir des
propos
d'amoureux à la fin de Laé
Didier Barb submergé par l'émotion prend
sa belle-mère par la main et la comagne
jusque devant le cercueil
il jure de ne pas laisser ce crime
impuni il jure qu'il retrouvera celui le
salot qui a fait ça il jure qu'il fera
justice lui-même le cas échéant nous le
dit il n dit faut le retrouver faut le
retrouver parce que je le tuai moi-même
mais
retrouver à partir de ce jour-là Didier
Barbeau dépéri a vu deil et ne vit plus
que dans l'espoir de découvrir qui a
assassiné sa femme mais l'enquête est au
point mort et c'est de la manière la
plus inattendue qui soit qu'elle va
rebondir nous sommes le 25 mai 2013 71
jours après la disparition d'Anne barbo
ce jourl didier est invité à dîner chez
des amis mais à 20h30 l'homme n'est
toujours pas arrivé une femme fait alors
irruption elle s'appelle Stéphanie
Livet c'est une voisine et les amis de
Didier Barbeau ne la connaissent pas
plus que ça on la connaissait pas du
tout elle habite donc à 2 km et demi de
chez nous là mais on la connaissait pas
du tout Stéphanie Liv cette femme que
personne ne connaît et qui surgit au
beau milieu d'un dîner aurais-tu d'après
les amis de Didier une attitude pour le
moins étrange déjà on était en petit
comité intime on était à repa et elle
s'est imposée elle s'est assise et elle
s'est installée mais comme si qu'elle
était invitée quoi c'est vrai que là
elle nous a fait peur quelque part elle
fait peur parce que elle est très
impulsif on peut pas en placer une il y
en avait que pour elle elle elle a dit
que Ben que Didier était très gentil que
c'était dommage que ce qui lui était
arrivé mais pouvit réconforter elle nous
dit ben moi je suis encore jeune je
peux je peux encore procréer et à la
suite de tout ça en fin de compte dans
la conversation on s dit mais en fin de
compte elle parlait sans doute de
Didier nous on est tombé des des n quand
on a entendu
ça on se disait elle elle a quelque
chose il y a un problème avec elle il y
a un très gros problème
connait trop de choses elle est trop
près de Didier son affolement était
suspect on s'est dit tiens pourquoi que
elle est aussi affolé que ça après à
chercher Didier mais qui est cette femme
dont les propos sont incohérents que
vient-elle faire dans un dîner où elle
n'a pas été
invité les convives ne vont pas tarder à
le savoir
me dit vous êtes des amis de
Didier didier est parti sans doute en
forêt pour se
suicider immédiatement les amis de
Didier tent de le joindre sur son
téléphone portable après tout Stéphanie
Liv dit peut-être vrai ils vont l'avir
au téléphone et il va les envoyer
promener il va leur dire écoutez
laissez-moi tranquille laissez-moi à ma
place en gros foutez-moi la
paix inquiier que leur amis fasse une
bêtise les amis appellent les gendarmes
qui vont les aider à localiser le
téléphone de Didier Barbeau et ils vont
le borner dans un rayon de k dans la
forêt de Saint-Michel
etchanveau Saint-Michel etchanveau
souvenez-vous c'est là que le corp d'an
Barbeau a été
retrouvé Didier aurait-il décidé de
mettre fin à sé jour au même endroit
tout pousse à le
croire et là bah prendre pas de combat
quoi tout le monde est parti cette dame
là est partie mon mari est parti Damien
Laurence ils sont partis tous les quatre
à la recherche dans la
et Stéphanie Liv va à nouveau surprendre
les proches de Didier
elle prend en main les recherches et
guide le groupe vers le chemin où la
voiture et le corps d'Anne barbau ont
été brûlé
elle les emmène directement à l'endroit
où a été retrouvé le corp barbau qui éta
qui était brûlé dans la voiture donc ça
veut dire qu'elle connaît directement
l'endroit où était la voiture elle a
aucune raison de connaîre cet endroit
l'attitude de Stéphanie Liv est pour le
moins étonnante com comment ça se
faisait qu' connaissa C endroit c'est un
endroit qui est très perdu quand mêmeut
connaître pour aller chercher le
Stéphanie elle est rentré dans la forêt
dans la forêt Saint-Michel mais en
sachant exactement où est-ce qu'elle
allait parce que celui qui connait la
forêt moi j suis allé une fois ou deux
fois c'est bourr des grandes de grandes
allées mais après c'est plein de petits
chemins sur les côtés faut vraiment
savoir où est-ce que vous allez
et c'est à quelques centaines de mètres
de là que les gendarmes découvrent
Didier
Barc à quelques minutes près l'homme
serait mort il est dans sa voiture et il
y a un tuyau qui relie le pot
d'échappement à l'habitacle donc il est
en train de tenter de
s'asphixier je suis rentré dans la
voiture pour le
sortir ça ça sentait largement le gaz
carbonique quand même il y en avait
quand même pas mal et il est dans un
état
d'intoxication avancé au dioxyde de
carbone on lui a dit mais pourquoi que
tu fais ça qu'est-ce qui t'arrive il a
dit moi j'en ai marre je je veartir avec
pu c'est
tout alors qu'il est emmené à l'hôpital
ses amis se posent de nombreuses
questions qui est réellement Stéphanie
Liv quelle est la nature de sa relation
avec
Didier
lorsqu'il sort de l'hôpital pressé par
les questions de ses amis l'agriculteur
explique que cette femme lui ferait
vivre un enferire et cela depuis des
mois il explique globalement que cette
femme est une voisine qu'il la voit
régulièrement traîner autour de chez lui
que c'est à la limite du harcèlement il
dit oui elle arrête pas de me harceler
elle croit que on va va être ensemble et
tout ça et en fin de compte il a dit
mais on a dit fait quelque chose c'est
possible à la gendarmerie on lu a dit
ben dépose une main courante il a dit
oui oui je vais je vais le
faire et les amis de Didier Barbeau ne
sont pas les seuls à se poser des
questions sur cette mystérieuse
voisine depuis plusieurs semaines
Stéphanie Livet et dans la ligne de mire
des gendarmes les gendarmes étaient sur
la piste de Stéphanie
Livet parce qu'ils avaient vu son
véhicule évidemment après les faits qui
rôait autour du domicile de Didier
Barbeau les gendarmes enquêtent
discrètement depuis plusieurs jours sur
cette Stéphanie liv et ce qu'ils vont
découvrir va venir bouleverser
l'enquête Stéphanie Livet a 38 ans elle
est aide soignante depuis 3 ans elle
habite VRI et dans la commune le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est que cette
femme ne fait pas l'unanimité j'avais
trouvé qu' é un peu bizarre la mairie
elle était toujours un petit peu
révoltée énervée
elle n'est pas très connue sur la
commune de VRI car elle elle ne
participe pas à la Vie associative aux
actualités enfin tout ce qui est
organisé c'est quelqu'un qui prend
toujours un petit peu de recul et qui
apparemment apprécie de ne pas être trop
connu mère de deux enfants Stéphanie Liv
vit séparé de son conjo
int et si elle connaît bien le couple
barbau c'est parce qu' elle aussi a
perdu un enfant une petite fille décédée
à l'âge de 10 ans c'est ce grand malheur
qui l'a fait se rapprocher de
l'agriculteur et de sa femme Anne barbau
et en questionnant les villageois les
gendarmes vont en apprendre un peu plus
depuis quelques mois il y a des rumeurs
d'infidélité une infidélité commise par
Didier Barbeau avec avec une femme une
femme que certains identifient comme
Stéphanie Livet ces rumeurs d'infidélité
vont croissantes des Riverin aurait vu
Stéphanie Livet aux abords aux alentours
de la ferme en train de surveiller avec
des jumelles Didier
Barbeau qu'est-ce qu'elle fait avec des
jumelles là-bas qu'est-ce qu'elle
regarde mais moi à cette époque là
j'étais loin de m'imaginer qu'elle était
en train de surveiller bar dans sa
ferme selon les rumeurs cette relation
entre Didier Barbeau et Stéphanie Livet
aurait débuté bien avant la disparition
d'Anne
barbo l'agriculteur ce mari inconsolable
qui depuis le jour de la disparition de
sa femme remue ciel et terre serait donc
un homme infidèle mais est-ce le seul
secret de Didier
barbau en mettant Stéphanie sur écoute
téléphonique les gendarmes ne vont pas
tarder à faire d'incroyables
découvertes il découvre on le sait que
les relations qu'entretient Didier avec
Stéphanie Livet sont des relations
sentimentales et beaucoup plus que
sentimental il découvre que Didier n'est
pas du tout réticent à cette relation
sentimentale il ressort de leur
discussion il ressort de leur contact
téléphonique qu'ils ont une relation qui
dure depuis déjà un certain temps et
quand tout état de cause Didier n'est
pas tout à fait le mari est ploré qu'il
veut faire croire Didier Barbeau et
Stéphanie Livet serait donc amant et
cela depuis plusieurs années alors
aurait-il pu vouloir éliminer l'épouse
de venue
gênante dès lors les gendarmes vont
privilégier la piste
passionnelle 4 mois après la mort d'Anne
Barbeau l'enquête se concentre sur les
deux nouveaux
suspects en étudiant la téléphonie les
enquêteurs découvrent que le téléphone
de Stéphanie Liv a activé une borne dans
la forêt où la voiture et le corps
calciné d'Anne ont été
retrouvés Stéphanie Livet aurait donc
été sur ce chemin perdu dans la nuit du
15 au 16 mars 2013
[Musique]
à32 que pouvait-elle bien y faire qu pas
des gendarmes de découvrir que Stéphanie
Livet se trouvait dans le bois de
Saint-Michel
etchanveau la veille de la disparition
d'Anne à l'endroit où on l'a retrouvé et
ce n'est pas tout 10 minutes plus tard
au même endroit toujours la veille de la
disparition c'est cette fois le
téléphone d'Anne barbau qui active la
même borne que faisaient ces deux femmes
en pleine nuit dans cette forêt ça veut
dire que Stéphanie Livet peut avoir été
impliqué dans toute cette affaire et
qu'en même temps Didier Barbeau a
camouflé les
choses c'est à ce moment de l'enquête
qu'un nouveau rapport d'analyse va venir
conforter les doutes des
enquêteurs les gendarmes reçoivent
également le résultat d'expertise du bol
alimentaire de ce qu'avait mangé Anne
Barbeau juste avant de mourir le contenu
de ce bolet alimentaire est
véritablement stupéfiant et
contrairement à ce que soutient Didier
Barbeau elle dans le dans l'estomac elle
n'a pas de petit déjeuner mais elle a
les les restes du dîner de la veille un
steak de la viande et des haricot
verts les experts sont formels Anne
Barbeau est décédée 2 he après avoir
pris son dîner or souvenez-vous Didier
avait déclaré que sa femme avait dormi à
ses côtés toute la nuit et avait disparu
le matin après le petit-
déjeuner Didier aurait donc menti reste
à savoir
pourquoi pour le découvrir les gendarmes
décident d'interpeller les deux
amants le 26 novembre 2013 Didier barbau
et Stéphanie Liv sont interpellés à leur
domicile
respectif la région est sous le choc de
l'arrestation de ce mari courage qui
avait bouleversé par sa dignité et son
chagrin tout le monde veut croire à une
malheureuse méprise la première réaction
c'est c'est bien pour
Didier parce qu'au moins la garde à vue
va va mettre les choses au clair et ça
va
allinnocenti il croyait à son innocence
il croyait à l'amour qu'il portait à sa
femme demand la garde à vue on est
encore à 100 % avec
Didier dans les locaux de la gendarme
danger les interrogatoires
commencent dès le début de leur garde à
vue Didier Barbeau Stéphanie Livet comme
sur l'opposition il ne lâche rien au
gendarmes au fil des heures les deux
suspects ni avoir fait disparaître Anne
barbau même si tous les deux
reconnaissent être amant petit à petit
au fil des des auditions au cours de la
4e audition Didier Barbeau a commencé à
reconnaître par er par escalier comme
disent les
enquêteurs certains
fait Didier et Stéphanie av vous d'abord
entretenir une relation amoureuse depuis
3 ans dans le plus grand des
secrets et à les écouter c'est une
histoire
sérieuse Stéphanie Liv aurait fait la
promesse à Didier d'avoir un enfant de
lui Didier barbe rêvit d'avoir un enfant
rêv d'avoir un enfant à lui un enfant
qui venait de lui un enfant biologique
ne pouvant pas lui donner d'enfant
Stéphanie livette lui a dit moi je
pourrais en avoir puis tu auras un
enfant qui qui sera de ton sang et de
toi alors ce désir d'enfant serait-il à
l'origine de la mort d'Anne barbau les
gendarmes sentent qu'ils tiennent un
mobile ils vont maintenant renforcer
leur pression sur l'agriculteur et sa
maîtresse car d'après eux Anne barbau
n'aurait jamais été au courant de leur
idyle et n'était donc pas un obstacle à
leur relation
et au bout d'un jour et demi de garde à
vue totalement épuisé les deux amants
vont se mettre à
table alors au bout de d'une journée et
demi ou de jours de garde à vue
Stéphanie Livet et Didier Barbeau
passent aux
aveux Didier Barbeau et Stéphanie Livet
à vous qu'ils ont fummenté depuis
quelques jours quelques semaines un plan
pour se débarrasser d'ne Barbeau pour
l'assassiner ils ont échafaudé un
stratagème
diabolique et selon eux voici comment
cela se serait
passé vendredi 15 mars c'est cette
nuit-là que les deux amants auraient
choisi pour mettre leur plan à
exécution comme convenu did Didier
aurait dîné comme d'habitude avec sa
femme à la ferme stphanie serait alors
rentré discrètement dans le garage de la
maison pour se
cacher et conformément au scénario
qu'ils avaient préparé elle aurait
prévenu Didier par SMS
elle lui explique qu'elle est qu'elle
est dans dans la dans la ferme cachée
dans le garage et qu'elle est prête à
agir c'est le signal Anne kine en face
de son mari ne se doute de
rien ils expliquent que leur plan aurait
été d'attirer Anne dans le garage et de
l'attaquer par
surprise alors après avoir reçu le SMS
de sa maîtresse Didier aurait quitté la
table en prétextant qu'il devait aller
aux
toilettes c'est là enfermé qu'il aurait
attendu que sa maîtresse mette à
exécution la phase suivante de leur plan
couper l'électricité pour que Anne tombe
dans le
piège à ce moment précis Stéphanie Liv
coupe le courant de la maison pour
forcer Anne barbo à venir le
[Musique]
rétablir au moment où Anne barbo entre
dans le garage pour rétablir
l'électricité Stéphanie Livet lui saute
dessus et une bagarre
débute sentant que les choses tournent
mal ou pas comme prévu Didier Barbeau
sort des toilettes et et décide
d'intervenir il rentre dans le is une
bche et frappe sa femme à la tête la
faisant tomber dans les pommes mais ne
la tuant pas sur le
coup les deux amants racontent qu' barbo
éta inconscient et respir
encore ce serait Stéphanie Liv qui
aurait mis un terme à cette exécution
programmée
elle aurait étranglé sa rivale avec de
la ficelle agricole sous les yeux de son
am
[Applaudissements]
ensuite le couple aurait décidé de se
débarrasser du
corps les deux amants chargent le corps
d'Anne barbau dans le coffre de sa
voiture et l'emmène en forêt de chanveau
dans un lieu qu'il connaissent un lieu
isolé en se disant que personne n'aura
idée d'aller la retrouver
là puis Didier sa maîtresse aurait
aspergé la voiture
d'essence l'aurait
enflammé détruisant ainsi la voiture et
le corps d'Anne
barbau mais leur plan ne se serait pas
arrêté là c'est à cet instant-l que le
plan est véritablement le plus
diabolique pour brouiller les pistes il
décide d'aller encore plus loin en effet
afin d'éloigner les soupçons les deux
amants auraient fait croire à un crime
crapuleux Didier et Stéphanie auraient
éparpillé des effets personnel
appartenant à Anne à deux endroits
différents la guêre et le chéquier dans
lequel ils auraient pris la peine de
retirer C chès pour accroître la thèse
de l'enlèvement et puis ils reviennent à
VR et ils décident ensemble de de ne
plus se voir pendant quelques temps pour
ne pas attirer l'attention de
l'entourage sur leur
couple alors que Stéphanie Liv la
maîtresse se fait
discrète
chose incroyable Didier lui s'occupe de
convaincre ses amis sa famille les
gendarmes et la presse de sa sincérité
il va contacter tous les journaux il va
se montrer en couverture des journaux
pleurant montrant la photographie de son
épouse
didieros aussi le rôle du Marie
désespéré et tout fonctionne à merveille
a rien on a pas de nouvell on pas de
voiture aucune
aucune
piste c'est donc Hagar et avec le
sentiment d'avoir été trahi que les amis
et les habitants de la région découvrent
que non seulement Didier aurait eu une
maîtresse depuis plusieurs
années mais aussi qu'ensemble il serait
à l'origine de la mort
d'Anne cette femme qui quelques jours
avant son meurtre se réjouissait de
savoir que dans quelques semaines un
petit garçon éthiopien allit rejoindre
leur
foyer mais c'était l'horreur l'horreur
l'horreur quand on a entendu le le
procureur le soir à la télé nous
annoncer ce que Didier et Stéphanie
avaient fait et ben je me suis écroulé
je me suis mise à
pleurer c'était c'était de la haine que
j'avais envers Didier on a été outré
complètement ça nous a démoli c'est on
était F age après lui on voulait plus le
voir on voulait plus le voir parce que
quand on nous a dit qu'il avait tué avec
une bûche non
[Musique]
mais il a menti
euh à tous les habitants de la commune
et à toute sa famille à toute sa famille
euh pendant pendant 8 mois il s'est
moqué de tout le monde des gendarmes des
journalistes de ses amis de sa famille
de tout le monde
nous aussi journaliste on a on a été
trompé par par ce Marie dans la peine à
qui on attendu nos nos micros nos
caméras nos appareils photos pour
l'aider à rechercher sa
femme nous aussi on s'est senti
[Musique]
trompé de leur côté à la fin de ces
terribles aveux Stéphanie Livet et
Didier Barbeau sont mis en examen pour
assassinat je les ai vu entrer dans dans
le bureau du du juge des libertés
Stéphanie Livet c'est c'est une petite
femme rousse qui arrive fatiguée à garde
mal peigné pas pomponné du tout et là
son avocate tente le tout pour le tout
pour éviter l'incarcération à sa cliente
elle explique que Stéphanie
Livet n'est pas l'instigatrice du crime
qu'elle a suivi Didier Barbeau et
qu'elle était dans une totale dépendance
affective par rapport à Didier
Barbeau Didier Barbeau devant devant le
juge des libertés le 28 novembre va
rester muet lui aussi il va arriver
cacher la tête sous la capuche de sa
parc noir lui aussi est pas très frais
il vient de passer de nuits en garde à
vue il a une barbe de 3 jours j'étais là
dans dans dans ce bureau au moment où on
leur a signifié
cette mesure de détention provisoire et
et j'attendais une une réaction de de
Didier Barbeau une réaction de de
Stéphanie Livet pour essayer de se
défendre pour essayer de de de mentir
une nouvelle fois mais mais ce jour-là
peut-être peut-être qu'ils étaient
soulagés d'une certaine manière
peut-être que ils ils avaient tellement
menti pendant 8 mois qu'ils avaient
besoin de dire enfin la
vérité
les deux amants sont immédiatement
incarcérés à la maison d'arrêt de
Nant pour les proches de Didier Barbeau
après la consternation vient
l'interrogation tous n'ont qu'une
question sur les lèvres pour quelle
raison Anne a-t-elle connu cette fin
tragique la réponse se trouve sans doute
dans l'histoire de ce couple en mal
d'enfant ça faisait plusieurs années
qu'il voulait véritablement avoir avoir
un enfant Didier bar savait qu'il en
avait la possibilité Anne Barb de son
côté elle c'était très compliqué parce
que en raison de problème de stérilité
et je pense que Didier barbau forcément
vivait mal cette chose là de pas pouvoir
avoir d'enfant et lui rêve d'avoir un
enfant biologique plus qu'un enfant
adopté un enfant biologique c'est donc
ce que Stéphanie Liv pouvait offrir
à mais alors pourquoi ne pas divorcer y
a-t-il une autre raison qui aurait
conduit les deux amants à commettre
l'irréparable on ne peut pas écarter un
mobile financier on ne peut pas écarter
un mobile financier dans la mesure où le
couple avait emprunté pour acquérir la
ferme avait emprunté pour acquérir leur
immeuble que les emprunts étaient encore
en cours et que les deux époux avaient
chacun une partie de l'exploitation
dès lors en cas de divorce Didier
n'aurait pas pu racheter la partie de la
ferme qui appartenait à sa femme il
risquait donc de tout perdre pour que la
ferme reste entière à lui il fallait
quene disparaisse
aussi aujourd'hui dans le bureau du juge
d'instruction les deux amants se
déchirent chacun rejetant la
responsabilité du meurtre sur
l'autre Didier Barbeau quant à lui est
revenu sur ses aveux il accuse
maintenant sa maîtresse d'avoir agi
seulle dans le garage lui étant resté
totalement impuissant face à la
détermination de
celle-ci il se dédoine totalement il
fait une marche arrière il va maintenant
charger Stéphanie Livet comme ça arrive
souvent il
va se sortir de la scène de crime dire
en gros que c'est elle qui a tout fait
qu'elle
ACCP devant le juge Didier Barb affirme
qu'il n'est pour rien dans la mort de sa
femme contrairement à ses premières
déclarations ce n'est pas lui qui aurait
assommé Anne avec une bûche c'est
Stéphan se qu'il l'aurait frappé à
mort et elle lui aurait fracassé le
crâne avec une
[Musique]
potipation
à l'aider à charger le cors et ensuite à
s'en débarrasser en
forêt et ensuite évidemment de jouer la
comédie pour essayer de sauver les
meubles et préserver cette histoire avec
Stéphanie au final Stéphanie maintient
qu'elle était sous l'emprise de Didier
et qu'elle n'aurait fait que lui
obéir Didier Barb lui explique que c'est
sous l'influence de sa maîtresse
qu'ilaurait aidé à se débarrasser du
corps lors d'une nouvelle perquisition
la poêle décrite par Didier Barbeau a
été retrouvée dans la ferme s'agit-il
d'une preuve suffisante pour changer le
cours de l'enquête que s'est-il passé
réellement cette nuit-là l'instruction
suit son cours dans l'attente d'un
procès Didier barbau et Stéphanie Livet
restent présumé innocents leurs avocats
respectifs n'ont pas souhaité s'exprimer
dans notre
émission
[Musique]